all right we're now live in the right
session i was wondering why i wasn't
seeing the things i
should see and turns out i picked the
july instead of the june one so we do
have all these
good questions here um let's see what we
got
do i have any advice for somebody with
too many interests to pursue
how do you overcome the indecision and
the sense that you're missing out on the
things you enjoy when choosing a path
so that's actually a good question
that's something i was just talking
about with a
young 18 year old student a
few days ago in philosophy
as in the wider world of things you
cannot do
everything you can't even do half of the
things available for you
and so it's natural to have worries that
like you're missing out on something and
in recent times people have even coined
that term
fomo fear of missing out right a kind of
anxiety
or despair about getting to the right
things
and you know it's impossible to do even
more than just a fraction
of the different things that present
themselves to you so if you go to
college
you can't major in every subject right
you can't take classes in every subject
if you're going to date this person well
unless they're cool with it you can't
date this other person over here
by the way managing more than one person
to date
is is a a lot of work and not something
i would actually wish on anybody
um if you're going to go to a restaurant
and have a hamburger well
you only have enough room in your
stomach so you're not going to be able
to also cram
i know pizza down there or whatever so
this is this is a real problem
um the question of too many interests to
pursue
so maybe what you should do is write
them all down
and then do kind of triage figure out
how to
order them you know and say okay some of
these interests i'm not going to be able
to
follow up on i'm going to sacrifice
those so that i can
focus in on these other ones over here
that i think are more valuable or more
important or
necessary to my existence
how do you overcome that indecision
well you at a certain point you just
have to make decisions
and there's a lot of different ways you
could orient that
um but the the sense that you're missing
out you
are missing out and so it's not you know
you don't want to try to get rid of that
reality
but you want to reframe how you
think about it how you feel about it so
you are missing out on some things
does that mean that you're missing out
on the things that are most important
if you think you're missing out on the
things most important change your
priorities so that you're doing those
things right
um and and after a while you could get
kind of cool with realizing that
you don't have to do everything and you
know you can't do everything
nitton says what advice would you give
to a person learning philosophy without
going to classes
um that's a good question too so
you know first of all realize that
you're not necessarily missing out on
something
going to classes if you go to classes
with a really great professor
obviously you are missing out on
something right i've had some
people who were very uh important
in in my education i actually did a
youtube video about that a long time ago
i think it was like nine
instructors who made an impact on my
life
and so in cases like that you know you
you would be missing out on something
but there's a lot of people who are
really crappy teachers
frankly you might you might do better
not
to study with them and just to study on
your own right
and so there's that aspect that
psychological aspect to it
and then you know a lot of it is kind of
like the how to
and what to go to stuff like do you
you know there's resources out there on
philosophy
the two main encyclopedias of philosophy
on the in
on the web internet encyclopedia
philosophy stanford encyclopedia
philosophy
those can be useful a lot of times
they're written in ways that are not
particularly
helpful for people who don't have a
thick background
there's lots of videos there's great
podcasts out there you know
for example the history of philosophy
with no gaps podcast
is really quite quite an uh achievement
right so that that's worth checking out
um and you know the more that you're
digging into these things
the more you can move from one to the
other and see them
referenced by each other and you can
build up i would actually create like a
google spreadsheet for yourself
of resources that you use
and then you know write a little
annotation for yourself this sucked it
wasn't very helpful
this is awesome this is good but watch
out for this sort of thing
and then you know see what other people
are doing you know ask questions on
twitter reddit hey what what are some
good sources on
x that's what a lot of people do um
william zen has a question about a
friend
my advice on how to tell a friend
politely i'm not interested in jordan
peterson she seems really kind of
obsessed with his body
of work well that is probably going to
be an area where
um just as if she had gotten obsessed
with
listening to madonna you know albums or
watching hgtv or something like that
where you're gonna
have to be like listen i like you but
i'm not into this and the first 10 times
that you told me about it
that was great but i'm not going to buy
into your obsession
if that's going to be an obstacle to the
friendship maybe we see each other less
you know i want to talk about things
other than jordan peterson i would just
be very direct
you know and and you know the thing that
will happen
probably after that she'll she'll be
like well why don't you like jordan
peterson and then he can say
i'm not playing that game i just told
you i don't want to talk about jordan
peterson
so we're not going to talk about jordan
peterson let's talk about this thing
over here instead you know and i mean
that could lead to the end of the
friendship if they
are really obsessed about it
just as with any other pop culture thing
i mean jordan peterson is effectively
pop culture you know
um it's just got a little bit more
intellectualist kind of take to it
but i think a lot you know here's kind
of a funny thing so you notice me
wearing this judas priest t-shirt right
there's not a lot of people going around
like there were you know
five years ago where judas priest
t-shirts like people were wearing iron
maiden
or metallic or ac dc shirts who never
listened to the bands right
and i think with with a lot of jordan
the ideas jordan peterson is drawing on
many of the fans
have never read ninja they've never read
dostoevsky they've never read
sultan heatsin or you know any any of
the other people he's referencing
and it's more like people wearing band
t-shirts to
you know because it's cool you know
but yeah i think i think you're gonna
have a hard time
with this particular friendship
i mean if you really really like them as
a person
and you think that this is just a weird
phase that they're going through
you you stick around and you you know
you don't necessarily indulge their
hobby which is what it is but
you uh you know set down some limits
all right mark smith is here he says uh
i hope i'm doing well i hope you're
doing well too over there mark
do i think someone like adolf eichmann
would fall under
aristotle's classification of a brutish
or beastial disposition
or merely vicious so a brutish
or beastial disposition is when the
higher part of ourselves
has been like irrevocably damaged like
you think about people who have
become seriously addicted to you know
some very destructive drugs like meth
heads or
you know heroin addicts or alcoholics
you know quite a long ways down the line
and they're like literally burning out
brain cells or people who have been
so traumatized aristotle actually brings
up childhood sexual abuse as an example
of this
that they can't get themselves out of
that cycle i would say no eichmann
eichmann was not
something like that as a matter of fact
you
you know you notice hannah iran talking
about how he's quoting kant and kind of
getting kant wrong
uh to justify his actions he's
he's vicious in aristotle's point of
view he has wrong-headed ideas
and habits af you know
affectivity about things um
arent you know diagnosed him with a kind
of thoughtlessness and i think this is
something that is there
in a lot of vice alistair mcintyre
somebody who's
written about this in various places
the kind of inability to
see how other people are going to be
affected or to care about that
all right josiah barnes could you expand
on your problems with analytic
philosophy of religion who said i have
problems
you know i think i think a lot of
analytic philosophy when it turns to
particular
topics is is kind of like reinventing
wheels
and wasting a lot of time never really
getting to the points of things
because they want to be you know so
methodical in what they're doing
i think a lot of philosophy of religion
in the 20th century whether analytic or
not
is often based in not having done the
adequate reading
of classic sources and philosophy of
religion so there's
there's a historical problem as well
and i think a lot of analytic philosophy
of religion is just boring um
but you know different people are into
different things
i mean if you can't take anselm and make
him
and make his texts which are
intrinsically interesting
interesting in your article on it why
should we read your crap you know
um if you can't get the ontological
argument right
which it's not an ontological argument
anyway from
anselm and you have to reframe it in
terms of concepts that don't map on to
anselm
which anselm in his talk with ganilo
said i am definitely not saying that
why should i read your crap you know i
mean time is short
life is short we should focus on the
stuff that's actually
making real contributions there's some
great analytic philosophy of religion
read john wisdom
you know he's got this article gods that
gets excerpted
read the whole article it's really cool
stuff uh read the university discussion
that followed from that
but should i read plantinga
i mean if you if you have to sure but
it's really not that
that interesting you know uh
raw wood my question is simply is it
possible to achieve justice without
judgments well
i can answer that very simply no it's
not possible to live without judgments
so why would it be possible to achieve
justice without judgments
um you're making judgments all the time
whether you like it or not it's part of
what it means to be
a rational animal um so that's kind of a
non-starter
right all right zeno says is retributive
justice an
effective should be effective not
affective method and dealing with
punishment
and as justice in the interest of the
stronger so two totally separate
questions right
um so is retributive justice blah blah
blah blah
at that level of generality you can't
say anything i mean
is it effective in this situation is it
effective in these kinds of cases that's
where we can actually get some traction
and say
yeah in this kind of society it works in
this kind of society it doesn't
you know um but
as as one single globalized topic that
doesn't work at all
um and is just as the interest of the
stronger thrasymachus thinks it is
some other people think it is but
there's good arguments to say that
it's not that i mean any really
reductive
concept of justice is probably going to
be wrong
you know if you read aristotle's nick
and mccain ethics book
five that is the thing that he begins
with he says well people argue a lot
about justice
why do they get in so many arguments
about justice because it doesn't name
just one thing right so there isn't
a single definition of justice or if you
go to cicero's
on duties right where he lays out what
justice consists in
he splits it into strict justice
which includes several different things
and benevolence
which includes several different things
or if you look at john stuart mill's
utilitarianism chapter 5 where he talks
about
what we think justice is he names about
five different things
so any simple simple-minded
justices justice definition is almost
guaranteed to be
wrong when applied to justice as a
totality
right uh maida clay asks about friedrich
jameson
um somebody who i used to read quite a
bit um
started reading a singular modernity and
finding it interesting i haven't read
that one
um you know prison house of language was
really big
back in the day as was his book
post-modernism the cultural logic of
late capitalism
which is uh something i i often
recommend to people who are going to
talk about postmodernism that they read
that book first
before they start you know spotting off
about post-modernism um
i think jameson is is interesting he's
worth reading
um like a lot of people who are based in
continental philosophy
he can sometimes be seduced into
jargoning away you know and
sort of like making assumptions that
this person got things right or this
person got things right
um he's i wouldn't say he's sort of
more of an interpreter than an original
thinker which i don't have a problem
with i think that's that's often quite
quite what we want
um and uh you know his works are worth
worth checking out i would say
um
well here's a really interesting
question from sam
what do you think of the idea of
geniuses in a certain field
or a genius in general is genius
undeniably real a social phenomenon or
something else
i think genius is actually [ __ ] um
quite frankly
and it's it's um
i mean you can say that some people are
more talented at some things and have
certain abilities but most of the time
the people who
do the best stuff it's due to three
factors
one of which is you know disciplined
working on stuff
another is having the right connections
and and you know being promoted in the
right ways then the third is like just
dumb luck
you know uh being in the in the right
not just right place at the right time
being in the right epic at the right
time
to do something um genius is one of
those concepts that
i think is actually more harmful than
helpful
in understanding things
and nobody's ever been able to give
any sort of useful
definition of what it consists in it's
more like a buzzword
that people employ and it's
you know how people talk about the god
of the gaps in philosophy of religion or
theology that's what genius is
in terms of social development or you
know
determining what the differences are
with people when i hear somebody
described as a genius i just tune out
because i'm like well that person
maybe that person really is really smart
or talented but whoever's talking about
them doesn't really have much to say
that's that's useful um you know great
example of somebody who's
who is incredibly talented who died
recently unfortunately
uh the late great eddie van halen right
had a incredible musical talent um
could play all sorts of instruments um
but is that super unusual no i mean i
went to school with a kid who had
perfect pitch
and could like play any tune basically
from from
ear and you know puttered around in a
couple bands played violin in the youth
symphony orchestra of chicago and
burnt out my great-grandfather
he organized a band in the great
depression of a bunch of street kids
that he got
uh instruments from taught them all the
instruments
you know uh this sort of talent is not
that unusual right um
but what did eddie van halen do that was
different
van halen is a band with him
his older brother alex on drums
eventually michael anthony they had some
other bassists but michael anthony on
bass and david lee roth on vocals
they practiced six days a week
four hours every day that's a lot of
time
put in on those songs and that's that's
time that they're practicing not the
time that they're playing in clubs or
things backyard parties or stuff like
that if you really want
to develop your talents um that's what
you do you put in a lot of work you know
when i was studying languages i would
i would spend you know hours a day on on
greek or on latin or german
you know um and you just you put in the
time if you have some native talent
that that can be actualized by that and
then there's other things where
um you you discover you're just never
going to be that great at it right
so i think i think genius is kind of a
a concept that's probably run out its
time
um so yeah uh
jared jared zedge
um asks for recommendations for
bookstores down in milwaukee
so yeah that's a good question if you're
here in milwaukee
there are three places i actually
there's four places i would suggest
one of them is a national chain called
half price books
and there's one out in brookfield
um and you know they're they're pretty
good they have a large stock of stuff
um and you know sometimes they have cool
stuff sometimes they don't
there's a better used bookstore called
downtown books which is actually just a
few blocks from here
and that's uh that's quite nice
um they
they are you know a bit more specialty
they go a little bit deeper into stuff
there's also used books at um
the renaissance books store which is at
the milwaukee airport
before you actually go into security
you know go past the security thing to
the gates there's this bookstore that's
been there for
i don't know it was there when i left
milwaukee in in 95
um and it's always been pretty amazing
i haven't been there for for quite some
time but people tell me it's still
up to to snuff there used to be a couple
other really great used bookstores
in here but they all have gone away but
we also have another great fixture which
is boswell books
boswell's is important not just for
selling books
but also for organizing all sorts of
events that in the past have been face
to face and they'll be going face to
face again
and then they've been doing things
online as well and so they're they're a
really great bookstore
as well i actually got to participate in
one of the events veronica roth the
author of the insurgent series and
and carve the mark and some of these
other young adult science fiction books
she um she was coming to town and
because of my worlds of speculative
fiction thing
um her agent reached out to me and said
would you like to be part of the
conversation
and i was like yeah i mean like my kids
are into her stuff and i'll
i'll read her new her new book and so
that was that was kind of nice and
and um and that was boswell so boswell's
doing events like that
so i would i would check those things
out
um all right
b says six shirt yeah this is the
defenders of the faith
arguably the heaviest of the heavy
albums by judas priest
right um
ryan says have i read the book lose a
stoic
i have not i have it on my bookshelf
because one of my friends
read it through and sent it to me but i
haven't gotten to it yet
um i'm not inclined to you know from the
start to say
yes that makes a lot of sense because i
i think you can say deleuze is more of
an eclectic philosopher but
i'm game to read it um jose says have
you read after finitude i have not
so uh jad
thanks for your efforts just wanted to
ask you about aerosol i'm reading the
metaphysics i'm struggling
at many passages are you going to
continue the core concepts on it
i might but not not at any point in time
in the near future because i've got so
many other core concept videos i need to
shoot four classes
coming up this summer classes in the
fall
most of my core concept stuff is things
that i'm teaching my
my own students i do sometimes
take commissions uh people pay me to
produce the videos that they
they want to see so that that's always a
possibility
um but yeah the metaphysics
i mean i might it's a good question i
mean there's some
some books of it that are kind of
self-contained that might be
good for me to go through but i do have
so much other stuff i need to do before
that
um kai
asks do i think philosophy should be
taught at the grade school
through high school levels that'd be
nice
um we don't have that
here in america in general
with a few exceptions if you're in a
religious school
you might get philosophy taught as a
religion elective that's that's the way
i got it in
in my school in high school but it might
suck it might be done in a really
doctrinaire or even apologetics kind of
way
it might also be taught in high school
as an english or a social studies
elective
and then you got to get a teacher who's
willing to do it
and i think the biggest issue would be
you know this will probably tick some
people off but
a lot of k-12 educators are not very
good educators
you know they they learn enough
to do their thing they major in
education and then they major in history
or they major in mathematics and
you know when i was in college the math
at majors were always at the bottom of
the math classes
same thing with the history of majors
same thing with the english ed majors
and it was in part because they were not
very many of them were not
in it primarily because they loved their
discipline they were in it because they
were
education majors that needed to have
something to to teach
and we would have to train up an entire
cadre
of high quality philosophy instructors
or it would get you know we'd run into
all sorts of like
crappy teaching uh of philosophy but
then again you know a lot of the
philosophy teachers teaching in the
colleges and universities aren't very
good either so
maybe maybe it's not that big of a deal
you know
all right um here's a good question from
chad
does philosophy get easier eventually if
i keep reading carefully
yeah i would say it does
and that's partly because you're
building up
uh habits of doing something just as
much as if you're like you know learning
the flute right
it gets easier to finger the stuff over
time and to sight read
and all of that but it's also because
as you're reading more broadly
you can kind of fill in the pictures so
when you see like schopenhauer
talking about kant and also talking
about plato
if you've read the kant it's a lot
easier to understand what
schopenhauer's saying about content if
you've read the plato
it's a lot easier to understand what
schopenhauer is saying about plato
and it's also easier to say ah this is
where he's like
using them but diverging and doing
something kind of different
and this isn't the this isn't actually
what kant said but this is interesting
stuff that show up and how he's saying
so
there's two sides to it i would say
uh johann if hope this is not too
personal what made you come back to the
catholic
church there wasn't just like one single
thing there rarely is for anybody
a big part of it was studying anselm
basically to work on my latin and
aquinas
and realizing that the misconception
that had been
given across to me that if you're a
religious thinker you're probably not a
very good thinker
was complete [ __ ] and that a lot of
the uh
takes on their philosophy were wrong
and that there there might be something
to being
um part of the the christian community
that promoted thinking
um that was a significant part the mod
the modeling that was provided for me by
um other people in my department
and um you know reading other thinkers i
mean i can tell you that
graham greene was somebody important for
me
i think for people like me it was
important to
find other people who struggled with
questions of faith rather than like
finding god or finding religion or
finding the church and then everything
gets solved right
i i'm much more attracted to thinkers
who
their life gets more complicated once
they realize that there is this entire
spiritual dimension to things and it
didn't actually solve a lot of
a lot of problems for them but it
actually made things more complicated
um all right uh
juan pablo i'm trying to work on the
relationship between nietzsche and the
stoics do you have any advice
there isn't really any relationship
between nietzsche and the stoics other
than borrowing the idea of the eternal
recurrence um and getting the stoics
wrong on a lot of points
um kind of polemically
it's not like the stoics were a great
spur to nietzsche's thought
um and and you can say there's a bunch
of
you know it's not like nietzsche has a
take on the stomachs there's a bunch of
different passages
some of which where he seems to you know
be pretty
pretty on others where you're like ah
come on nietzsche
so i i would say you know if any advice
go through all of his works find every
reference to the stoic start mapping
them out
figuring out where they where they fit
in
and then you know reconstruct something
on it i'm sure there's also a ton of
secondary literature on that very topic
as well
um punit says
thanks for replying to emails
is it fair to say most philosophers and
most people who are interested in
philosophy are pessimistic
i wouldn't say that at all
i would you probably want to think about
where you're getting that idea from it
might be the mix of people that you're
reading
or like resources out there or it could
be like you know your friends who are
into it or
pessimists but no i i wouldn't say that
there's and i wouldn't say that
philosophers are like
unduly optimistic either there's very
got a discipline that in the west is
2500 years old
and um you know there's going to be a
lot of variance
in in in what their personality types
are like
um
it was a great suggestion following up
on the peterson thing
i'll chupacabra tell that peterson
obsessed friend i'm sorry
i only have time for primary sources so
let's say i don't want to get peterson's
nature i want to read nietzsche myself
that's actually not a bad idea um
all right art says do i believe in the
mystical metaphysically do i think
there's more fantasy to this reality
then we're led to believe so i don't
know what the mystical means
that's one of those terms that you know
ask 10 people you get 10 answers
um so i i don't know how to answer
that quite frankly do i think there's
more fantasy to this reality
if by fantasy you mean something like
do we human beings contribute through
our imagination which is what fontasia
is originally to the reality that we
live in yeah a lot of our reality is
in fact um fantasy and a collective
fantasy
um but i don't know that that ties in
with the mystical at all
necessarily all right um
a lot of back and forth about peterson
here
uh okay so b
asked what are your thoughts on folks
like emerson william james whitman as
they relate to american philosophy
well they don't relate to american
philosophy they are american philosophy
right
so emerson is is one of the most
important
of the transcendentalist movement and
that's you know front and center in
american philosophy
james may be the most important
pragmatist except for you know what the
dewey people say
um and so that's all of the american
philosophy does whitman figure into that
depends on how far you're willing to
push philosophy
i mean if whitman is going to be part of
it maybe emily dickinson gets to be part
of it as well
and other poets i don't have a problem
with that myself i like william james
he's really grown on me as i've i've
gotten older because
i'm i'm pretty attracted to i call
myself a cicerone eclectic but
i could also call myself something like
a jamesian pluralist as well
um emerson i can kind of take or leave
whitman you know i i appreciate his
stuff i'm not like a huge fan
i think classical american philosophy is
well worth teaching and i have
been fortunate enough to be able to
teach it and to have gone to a graduate
school
where that was one of the three main
areas we had analytic
continental and classical american
philosophy and then if i wanted to do
like ancient greek i went to the
classics department
and to interestingly enough the english
department where they did rhetoric
um so yeah i mean they're
they're definitely worth reading um
all right uh sir toke a lot i know that
i love that you're into metal how do you
feel about death metal bands like
obituary and massacre
i am not into death metal um
if you're gonna like talk in terms of
like the the
plethora of genres that burgeoned out
basically in the 90s
uh perhaps with some roots in the 80s
uh after the classic phase then i would
say that the
sort of genres that i'm into are doom
and
um power and a new wave of traditional
heavy
metal rather than death metal or black
metal or
pirate metal or pick whatever else you
you want
um but i i focus more on
what we call classic heavy metals so
stuff from the 70s
through the 80s and then the bands that
continued after them were
influenced by them so you know you see
me wearing a judas priest t-shirt here
um that's that's part of that classic
medal sometimes they'd get influence
i like thrash too i should mention
that's one that does have its roots in
the 80s
pretty pretty solidly so i don't i don't
listen to a lot of new bands
um the ones that i do tend to be in
those other genres
like you know mostly doom metal stuff
like orchid
you know i really like them but i don't
i don't listen to a lot of black metal
i mean i do watch metapocalypse
i i like that um
but that's just because i think they're
so funny and also the drummer is from
wisconsin right
um
well a lot of back and forth about
peterson here really opened up a womb
uh cola moose how influenced by
heraclitus do you think marcus aurelius
was and
and how if he was do you think that
influence shows
yeah that's a good question so that we
do know that there were there wasn't
just heraclitus and his writings
there were heraclitians as
maybe an organized school maybe not we
know that they did exist
as a school because there are references
to them
and lucian makes fun of them lucian the
the
comic writer right and if one way to
tell that you're somebody is that the
comics will make fun of you
so we know that there wasn't just
heraclitus's
on nature floating around which we've
unfortunately lost
all but fragments of we know that there
were people who
espoused heroclitianism
and we know that some of the stoics were
influenced by some ideas of heraclitus
although
much less than you know other thinkers
like socrates or the cynics or people
like that
and we could say that there are
thematics
in marcus aurelius that seem
that seem heroclitian influence like the
you know he says over and over again
um consider how
you know things are fleeting and they're
breaking down into their elements and
all of that
so that that could tie in with the
everything flows idea
um the notion of these things
kind of cyclically repeating themselves
seems to be their heraclitus as well but
it's it's difficult to
to see directly uh isaac what are
thoughts on spinoza's ethics
it's an interesting book i think it's
one of those books
like hegel's phenomenology that has
developed a mystique around itself and
interestingly spinoza had that mystique
for the
german idealists and when i say mystique
i mean that in the sense
of there you know people talk about it
without really
understanding it and the perspective
that it that it's
you know articulating that well and
they're like oh cool stuff
man you know and so it becomes sort of
like a
a thing that you go back and forth with
between people and communication
without digging super into it i mean if
you're really a spanosian
trying to live out his ethics you are
going to have a very particular kind of
life you know
and i i don't see a lot of reflection of
that in
most of the people that are into spinoza
i myself
i mean i've never really considered
um spinoza's perspective
plausible i do think it's an interesting
work i mean it's sort of like with hume
right i don't consider hume all that
plausible but i read his work and teach
his work occasionally too
um so you know spinoza's
worth checking out um he's uh
he's got some interesting things to say
ultimately wrong i think
um but you know he's worth checking out
uh yong how would stoics handle
addictions well there's no simple answer
to that
i think part of it would be figuring out
what you're actually addicted to in your
addiction
some people are addicted to say alcohol
and it's not because they just love
getting drunk all the time it's because
they
didn't deal with some disabling traumas
in their life and
then found themselves at the point where
they lost sight of why they started
drinking in the first place and you'd
have to
reconstruct that and stoics wouldn't do
any different i think than aristotelians
or
platonists when it comes to the therapy
of of the emotions or a lot of modern
you know psychotherapists and then they
would work
on figuring out what you can actually
change in what you can't change i mean
if you
grow up in a family of people who drink
all the time
and you live in a culture that pushes
that and you
have become yourself physiologically
dependent about alcohol you're not gonna
be able to snap your fingers and
just no longer be you you can snap your
fingers and not drink
for a little while but you can't like
change the desire
automatically and so you you chip away
at it you'd use certain
um practices and you would like figure
out what you actually do have control
over what you don't have control over
so you know there isn't any one single
thing that a
stoic would do uh michael
says what do i think of mortimer adler
and the great books movement
i think it was uh on the whole a good
thing i i've never been impressed by
adler myself
the way especially the way that
adlerians are impressed by him
there's actually almost something like a
sect around him
of people who think that he's you know
just amazing
most of the times that i've read his
stuff i've been like oh yeah yeah okay
that makes sense that makes sense i
don't buy that you know
i i don't i don't think he's a brilliant
great thinker who who
made major you know lasting
contributions
but you know he's sort of like um
the adlerians are sort of like the
people who follow
uh the institute of general semantics
people who follow albert korbinsky right
he said some interesting stuff about
language and all that
but it winds up being much more of a
um well it really reminds me of the
thing that that that
chest off says about masters and
followers you know
there's this almost kind of like
devotional aspect to it
um getting people to read great books is
good
getting him to read it the way that
mortimer adler wants you to could be
helpful for some people but
i always found it kind of stifling and
i never i never really found those types
all that that interesting
oh eric here's a great question best
priest album for
a noob um
so that's a challenge right because they
have this massive
catalog the first thing i was tempted to
say is like you know
one of the best hits albums right
because then you get a mix but that's
kind of cheating isn't it
um screaming for vengeance
i would say um that is from
it's not the heaviest album defenders of
the faith that comes right after it and
and in certain respects ram it down are
heavier
um but it's it's a good representation
there's a lot of good catchy tunes on
there
you've got every one of the players
at their their prime right
um so i i would go with that one and
i mean it's not my favorite priest album
my favorite priest album is sin after
sin
but that's earlier on um
i mean that's a good one too you know if
you want to if you want to get a sense
of the 1970s judas priest
at their best sin after sin if you want
the 1980s judas priest
you know young and hungry and breaking
into the u.s
screaming for vengeance although there's
a lot of other great albums along the
way too
right um
asian the domination what is a useful
language to learn
any language that's going to give you
the possibility of communicating with
people or
reading and understanding people that
you didn't have before so
if portuguese affords that to you then
portuguese is a useful language to learn
if tagalog is you know going to do that
for you then that's a useful language to
learn
all right um sam what advantages if any
does continental philosophy have over
analytic and vice versa
none because there is no such thing as
continental philosophy
or analytic philosophy as like blocks
that have all have the same
qualities or stuff like that you know
each of them names
um i mean continental is a much wider
set of traditions
you've got the phenomenologists you've
got you know marxism
you've got a dialectical philosophy in
other ways you've got
structuralism and post-structuralism and
all this other stuff mixed in with that
and then you know analytic philosophy
itself has a number of sub
subdivisions and and they they don't all
do the same thing or behave the same
thing so
most of these comparisons between
analytic and continental philosophy on
the really big level
are are not particularly useful or
or helpful all right uh
b a good prague metal band that deals
with stoic agnostic ideas is void
ceremony
okay i mean i'm not often listening to
bands
for philosophical content and the lyrics
imported there directly but
you know that that could be interesting
and i guess i do like some prague stuff
i mean i like queens reich um
[Music]
there was like a lot of interesting
prague stuff in the 90s around weird
time signatures like prong would be a
good example but
but i can't say i listen to a lot of
that anymore
um
[Music]
all right liquid snake what's the best
philosophy in dealing with a passive
aggressive co-worker
there isn't the best philosophy for
dealing with a passive aggressive
co-worker right
um if you're asking like what are the
best techniques for dealing with them
um maybe you know
realize that they're doing the pan this
is coming from epictetus right
um they're doing this passive aggressive
shtick because they're stuck in that
that's that's what
to them they think wrongly is the way a
human being ought to behave
and so instead of getting like angry
with them you can say oh you poor
miserable bastard
say that in your head not out loud uh
and then you you don't have to feel you
don't have to feel upset with them you
can just be like oh well
probably not gonna have a lot of
productive interactions with this person
um all right
trey dixon should one be pro society or
the other way around being against
society doesn't by any chance
mean hating society becomes more from
individual human expression just to make
it clear
um i don't really know what being
pro-society
would mean you know that that seems very
abstract um
you know i think you could say well what
about this society or this sub-society
that i live in
like you know coming from
growing up here in wisconsin right there
there was a culture that was
not particularly intellectually focused
and was you know a lot about like
drinking and hanging out
and watching the packers play or the
brewers of the box or
talking about that kind of stuff and you
know working at a job if you could get
one
um and you know should i be pro or
against that
i mean it might be better to be like pro
aspects and against
aspects you know and say what what do i
want to
have i don't know what it means to be
pro-society or
anti-society you know in a global way
so tyler have i had any psychedelic
experiences do i think their
consciousness expanding qualities it's
weird that philosophers haven't jumped
on the chance to fuel a new reality
many philosophers have experimented with
psychedelics i mean william james has
got essays on that i
always here's my take on it right and i
come from
both a friend group and family that have
you know have a lot of people who've
done psychedelics of different sorts
i tend to think that for
people who aren't very developed
and aren't particularly
particularly articulate they could be
interesting gateways into having new
consciousness
kind of things but the best of them
um can be done through like you know
visualization exercises or other things
like that
and you know smelling colors doesn't
seem to be something that i would
particularly
give a [ __ ] about you know i mean i
remember the kids in high school and
college would drop acid and recount to
me their experiences and i'd be like
well that's interesting but
not that interesting so i've never been
that
that attracted to those prospects um
i mean a lot of it just sounds like
having synesthetic experiences or
you know breakthroughs to realizing that
things are connected with each other we
can do that in other ways
that don't involve um messing around
with our brain chemistry
in those ways they could be you know
some things can be useful for people in
dealing with trauma
i would say but that's less about
philosophy that's more about
you know mental health um
and i don't know i i've never i've never
found the
arguments about opening up the doors to
consciousness to be very
very interesting um
not to say that you know nobody should
ever do that but
all right charles ring do you have any
reading recommendations on hypatia of
alexandria i do not because
we don't even know if she existed or not
any more than catherine of alexandria
um there aren't there aren't you know
it's interesting so i'm going to give a
little bit of a rant
we see these listicles where they're
like women philosophers who you ought to
read
and they almost always have hypatia of
alexandria in there
and then they'll have like simonda
bouvoir hannah rant or you know
mary wollstonecraft or people like that
who've actually existed
and um we have writings of you know and
and
most likely if of hype i've said this
about catherine of alexandria patroness
of
christian philosophers if she didn't
exist as
catherine of alexandria there probably
was some other woman who
you know in a town like alexandria who
did these sorts of things
but we don't have any records anything
that's really
all that um useful we've got
after the fact stuff and sort of
accounts
and i get kind of tired of seeing these
catherine of alexander her patient
alexandria
put into these listicles when instead
they should get rid of them
and just put people that we actually
know something about
um like you know we've got plenty of
medieval thinkers um
you know hildegard of bingham for one
right um
and we've got tons and tons of
you know from like the 18th century
onward to
to the 21st century great women thinkers
we don't need to engage in this
legendary stuff
so i know i don't have any reading
suggestions about hypatia of alexandria
johnny guitar is a good question that
maybe other people want to weigh in on
what are some good philosophy heavy
movies
um i used to show memento and dark
city quite often back when i first
started teaching i had dvds and i'd
bring them in and
we'd talk about them but i mean there
are so many movies
where there are philosophical themes
built into them the question is whether
they're handled well
or you know kind of heavy-handed
done um there's plenty of movies too
where people reference
philosophical ideas as well all right
nico says i want to thank thank me for
my series on hale's phenomenology it's
been useful
so the long ways to go you're very
welcome yeah and i still have a long
ways to go i still have
most of the religion section yet to do
and i have not been making
as quick of a progress on it as i would
like to
um but you know i'm doing what i can so
let me do a sound thing real quick it
doesn't look like i'm getting an
awful lot oh yeah okay
i'm seeing it on one thing and not
seeing it on the other thing but
hopefully everybody's hearing me all
right um
goder demeron has an interesting
question general thoughts on
virtue epistemology so virtue
epistemology for those who don't know
what it is
it's a movement largely within analytic
philosophy
doing a lot of reinventing of the wheel
saying that
there could be in order to do
epistemology maybe we need to have
developed states of character
and so you know guy axel has been a very
important early person
in it um virtue epistemology was
happening already
back with plato and aristotle and the
stomachs and
medieval thinkers and i mean descartes
is doing
uh some virtue epistemology itself
it's it's it's a case of people picking
out like a new field
and saying oh we're gonna do this this
cool project over here
and i've actually i mean i i was writing
stuff back in the
early 2000s pointing out to virtue
epistemologists saying
you're doing what we were already doing
over here
or phenomenology's been doing this or
you know the critical thinking movement
was was doing this so
yeah um
i i don't i mean it's it's interesting
stuff it's only really good
when it's engaged with the other people
who are
are doing those sorts of things and so
carried out as a discipline by itself it
often is kind of insular i would say
um all right let's see what else we have
so this is from b i once met a far right
punk who told me the linguistic strains
of continental philosophy or language
science that had rejected the
distinction between language science and
language art
okay i don't know what language science
and language art is supposed to be
uh here's an interesting question uh
olkov
is nick land as boring as everyone says
he is
i don't see a lot of people saying nick
land is boring i i think it's the
opposite extreme where
he is somebody like spinoza like hegel
where there's a mystique built up around
him
and so people think that he's like more
deep
or more interesting than that he really
is
but then when you ask them to articulate
what's going on they
they have a hard time saying what what
it is that that's really so attractive
about that for them and i've been
reading through fang numina
um which the the publisher was so kind
as to send me a copy of and i'll be
doing some you know
reviews about it later this summer i'll
also be going on the acid
horizon podcast to talk about it they've
invited me on
and i will say that my readings of land
so far have been very underwhelming
it's not that he's not any good
um but the kind of stuff that i'm seeing
in thing
numina is the kind of stuff that we were
just like presenting at conferences in
the 90s and continental philosophy
it's not like groundbreaking you know
mind-blowing kind of kind of stuff and
even the stuff towards the end of the
volume
where you know like it's all this coding
stuff well hell if you've ever read
avital ronald she was doing that stuff
back in the 80s you know so it's
it's just not that remarkable um
i don't know how this mystique developed
around him
that made him so you know so important
um but it doesn't seem to be
deserved um james do you have any
thoughts on berlin's two concepts of
liberty that that's one actually that i
i probably do need to do some core
concept videos on because i've wanted to
teach it in my class
i think that it's um ultimately
to need a distinction but
you know it's uh it's it's worth
checking out it's worth thinking
about um it's a helpful
it's one of those distinctions that's
helpful up to the point where it stops
being helpful and then starts standing
in the way like mulch distinctions right
that's probably enough about berlin um
johnny guitar have you guys read eve on
voight science fiction books
um i i certainly have i've been reading
him since i was
a kid and really enjoyed him i found a
a book a hardcover version that had
voyage of the space beagle
the world of nalae and slan in in my
uncle eubert's library and
as i i was like in sixth grade or
seventh grade just sort of devoured that
stuff and i'll actually be doing um
a talk in the worlds of speculative
fiction series
um so that'll be in august
on the weapon shops of isher the empire
of isher
volumes of even
let's see dialectics is science
objective and does it really offer us a
glimpse of truth with a capital t or a
fact
um i mean there's there's science as
sort of a construct and then there's the
sciences
and each one of them is is a vast
construct of all sorts of
ideas and you know um
ways of teaching things and measuring
things and doing experiments and
you know science blends into technology
so it's not like there's a thing out
there
called science that we can say offers us
a glimpse of
capital t truth um
certainly you know we get offered
glimpses of truths
right but
like truth is a transcendence not not
really
i mean science can't even really tell
you what sciences itself is about so
um that's kind of a problem uh
boomer says have you read blood meridian
i haven't read blood meridian or
i don't think i've read any core uh
cormac
mccarthy yeah um
the undertaker have i read existential
comics
i i'm actually mentioned on the
existential comics
site as a resource for you know
philosophy so yeah i've been
i've been reading his stuff for a number
of years he was
funnier a lot earlier on
now it's pretty hit and miss um
so you know i don't i don't
i don't read every one that comes out
anymore because they
they often disappoint um
ryan what can art communicate that pure
language can't i don't know what pure
language is but
um if you mean just like language
itself what can art communicate
um i mean you can do a linguistic
articulation of what an artwork
looks like but it's not the same thing
as having your eyeballs look at that
work of art
is it and like moving around it um
i mean you can say similar things about
like well what can
the culinary arts produce that language
can't
um totally encompass
right well you know the taste of a good
pizza
um but you know it's not that language
can't reference this stuff
obviously language can name an awful lot
of stuff and language can be
quite evocative of
sensory
impressions and you know
language can name emotions that are
evoked so language can do quite a lot of
stuff i would say
um what else have we got here
um
where were we here we go telly says have
you ever read the invention of moore
i have not i i've never even heard of it
so
maybe i'll have to check it out hiya
society what's your opinion on daoist
philosophy
i would say that um you know dow jia is
very interesting
um when you're actually reading the real
stuff not
like some westerners textbook
you know uh portrayal of it um
it's much more challenging when when
you're actually reading
um taoist philosophy stuff
um i mean i'm handicapped by the fact
that i can't read classical chinese
the way i can say german if i'm reading
stuff or ancient greek but
um so i i i'm not an expert on that sort
of thing
zeno says any books on phenomenology for
beginners i want to one day read
phenomenology of perception but i feel
like i should read around
him first so you're referencing marilla
ponte
i mean if you wanted to read some
marijuana stuff that is using
phenomenology but isn't the
phenomenology of perception
maybe read signs you know
read read some of his books that are
essentially essays put together
um i mean i i often
if i'm teaching this stuff i i have
people read earlier phenomenologists
like
husserl schaeler heidegger
actually has a uh encyclopedia entry
that he wrote
on phenomenology so that's that's kind
of nice
um but you know phenomenology of
perception is not
that tough of work you you could
you could jump into it you know the
first time you read through any
philosophical work you're not gonna
understand most of what you're
uh reading anyway most likely and you're
gonna have to go back to it
you know several other times so i would
i would check it out
uh namski my thoughts on foucault
reading discipline and punish currently
recommendations on similar books well
similar books in his corpus would be
madness and civilization
you know the order of things the history
of sexuality stuff
i think foucault is interesting i think
sometimes he's
his treatments of things when you know
the field that he's talking about you're
like
yeah this is a little bit too too too
neat of a narrative that he's
putting out here but you can certainly
certainly learn things from reading for
go
um it appears from the recent
revelations
i mean we knew he didn't have a
particularly good character anyway but
now
now you know it seems that he was
involved in some
some uh pretty bad abuse of children
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
we throw his books away
any more than we do with heidegger
having been a nazi right
um
all right uh
dial dialectic says why do you think
there's been such a resurgence in
hegelian philosophy in the past decades
to the extent where he went from big bad
status philosopher to someone with
genuine insight
i i don't think that's been the case um
i think that big bad status thing is is
still around
i mean you see you see um
people like basically lumping hegel and
marks in together and relying on some
watered down karl popper and
stuff like that and talking about how
like the left is using hegelian
dialectics and they of course mangle it
into the thesis antithesis synthesis
thing
so there's still plenty of those
misreadings of hegel out there
and i mean i don't know that there's
been
a much greater interest in hegel lately
it's been pretty consistent for the 20th
century
um and uh
yeah i mean i i i'm not i'm just not
seeing that
um
[Music]
but i i will say this there aren't that
many people interested in hegel
or at least there aren't that many
people interested in hegel in a
substantive way
um he does sometimes get brought up by
people on the left
but a lot of times you're like well i
don't think these people actually know
what they're they're talking about
because hegel is not just the master
slave dialect there's all this other
stuff going on as well all right uh this
is from telly what do i think of par fit
derek parfut how hard is it to formulate
a secular morality seems to offer a
blend
um i actually haven't read much profit
frankly
he's not somebody who i had a lot of
contact with
i suppose i should get around to reading
his his stuff
but he's just one of these people who i
i haven't had the time to
engage much with how hard is it to
formulate a secular morality i mean
people have been doing that
since antiquity so it's not that hard
the question would be how hard is it to
get everyone to buy into it and that's
infinitely hard
any morality you don't you're never
going to get complete buy-in
or how hard is it to defend a secular
morality or how hard is it to
conceptualize a secular morality
those are the sorts of things i guess
you would be asking
um and you know
there's a lot of people offering blends
of deontology rule utilitarianism
contract
contractarianism um that's been a
kind of pretty constant process even
people within deontological or
utilitarian circles
have been doing that john stewart mill
is a prime example right
if you look at utilitarianism his
one of his main works he is trying to
suck in
the things from deontology and virtue
ethics and say well we we
utilitarians can have that if you look
at
robert audi or other you know important
applied ethicists they're doing
similar things as well so i think you
know
we we probably actually do want a
um we want to have what's best about
utilitarian
thinking which is quite helpful in some
cases
and deontological thinking and things
that go beyond those two things um
and that capture what's what's useful
with the social contract i would say all
those are
are good things all right um
let's see
so johnny guitar are philosophers just
intellectual wankers who want to play
the smart card instead of knowing the
true nature of existence
well if they don't know the triggs you
know nature of existence
who do you think does um i mean
i i kind of think any question that
begins are philosophers just
is probably if somebody answers yes it's
because they've only known a few
philosophers
um and you know it's sort of like saying
are all construction workers blah blah
blah blah blah
i mean there's a lot of different kinds
of people doing construction work
i mean even in just one philosophy
department you walk down the hall
there's gonna be a lot of different
projects
and backgrounds and temperaments so
um i will say this there's been a long
history of
people saying things like that oh
philosophers their ivory towers and all
that
that's usually much more reflective of
the person saying that than it is about
the target of what they're saying
all right um ryan have you read the
glass
bead game by hermann hesse this is going
to be the constant theme have you read
this no i haven't read that
um all right derek what limits do you
think should be on behavior in public do
you think
what do you think about public nudity or
sex um i mean i think there could be
places for public community um
but having sex in public um
i don't know that probably needs to be
confined to
to a narrow range of of spaces
um i guess the question would be what's
what's the point of it
why are is it just because we want to
like sunbathe
and tan all the parts that we've got
that we usually don't
take out you know or as if we're trying
to like
you know get in people's faces
and make a point about things you know
really depends on
on the context i would say
um pedro says
okay what if in the matrix the movie the
matrix neo doesn't take
any of the pills that's a good question
i
i guess then he there's one or two
possibilities one would be
he's automatically taking the blue pill
he either does take the blue pill or
basically he just gets kicked back to
his his old reality
or maybe there'd be some third
alternative but it's just not sketched
out
what would that third alternative look
like
that's a kind of interesting question
isn't it
um so i i don't know
i don't i don't have any idea what would
be the
the case uh in that movie
it's almost like it's designed not to
allow you
to have a
a third possibility right
all right uh it's just skipped a little
bit here let me see
um
so leo parakaris as a professor of
philosophy
said that today about the wanker thing
because there are so many advancements
in all the other disciplines you don't
really involve philosophy
isn't that the case no that's not the
case and people
were saying that around the turn of the
century that's what aj air was saying in
language truth and logic
and it was as false back then as it is
now um
people who say that often have very
pie in the sky idealistic conceptions of
what the sciences do or the other
disciplines do
any discipline as you start progressing
in it you get to higher levels you start
you inevitably stray into philosophy
that's been the case for a very long
time and
philosophy turns out to be quite helpful
in terms of figuring out what to do with
your life
and making sense of things so you know i
i
i think that that unfortunately a lot of
people
without realizing that this has been
said and worked out in the past so many
times
go back to these old positions and
they're not particularly helpful um
and i guess you know if if if a
philosophy professor says something like
that
then the proper response to them is you
know like ludicrous is
move get out of the way because you're
taking up space that somebody
who could be doing real work in
philosophy could use
right uh thanks nathan that's that's
very nice uh
if you have a question go ahead and ask
it
um all right let's see
all right mark huffling will you give an
opinion on whether or not critical race
theory should be taught in the u.s if
this is a subject
you don't want to comment on it it's
understandable well first of all anybody
who's going to talk about critical race
theory needs to be able to like put on
the table
what exactly they mean by it and if it's
just talking about racism
you're full of [ __ ] get the hell out of
here right you don't belong in the
discourse
should we be teaching about um the
nature of racism
and how it's impacted uh our culture
yeah definitely i i'm very surprised
to find out because i when i was in high
school we learned about the tulsa
massacre and i'm very surprised to find
out
that so many other people don't know
about that and don't know about so many
other facts of american history
when this is like public record [ __ ] you
know
alexis de tocqueville democracy in
america in that great book where he's
talking about how american democracy has
got all these different features
he says right in there in the 1840s
there you know the there are two races
that
america uh and it is treatment of is
that a massive blot on it and it better
figure out what it's going to do
in relation to the red race meaning
native americans and the black race
i mean people have known that there's
fundamental problems that get replicated
generation after generation
um this should not be controversial
unless somebody
is is too sensitive to face it you know
yeah of course it should be in schools
just like other topics should be in
schools you know
um we don't need to hide ourselves from
reality because we're such snowflakes
that we can't
admit that racism exists and still has
effects on people today
so yeah i mean i i teach
people who nowadays are classified as
critical race theory in my classes
because i i think it's important to
encounter that sort of stuff for
students um and and frankly
i'll just go on record anybody who says
that it doesn't belong in schools or
it's too divisive
i just they're full of [ __ ] racists
that's
it there is no real
you know on its own grounds intellectual
critique of critical race theory
that should have it being excluded from
schools you can say what should be done
better
you don't want you know like crazy
people teaching it or things like that
but
that's about implementation that's not
about whether you do it at all
and so i mean it's more of a tell about
the person who
wants it not not in schools you know
um godward podcast do you have tips
about how to grow a literature channel
on youtube
i'm like 10 years behind you is it just
consistency consistency is a big big
part
youtube so there's there's resources out
there you can read about
youtube's algorithms and how they work
right youtube
wants to see um
ideally a video a day
now that's not really easy to do for
for most people but you can do you know
consistently a video a week
each week right um that also helps
people who are watching your your stuff
to say okay i can expect to see stuff
coming along
then you got to build a social media
presence these days as well
and you know
consistency is also important in the
sense that you just keep sticking with
it even if you get discouraged
you say well you know things are going
to go up and they're going to go down
like my videos for example
um my views during the semester they go
up up up up up and then like during this
summer interval they go
they go down significantly i'm getting
about half of the views right now
as i would be in say march when people
are like holy [ __ ] i gotta write a paper
on god where can i find
some stuff right and that's that's
that's
just it you know that's the way things
tend to go
all right um
[Music]
barklord what if anything does nietzsche
have to say about economics
about like how economics works not an
awful lot
except at sort of base levels about
people who are focused primarily on
economics he views them
as as you know lower um
i'd say that's sort of the grand theme
[Music]
um
diamond can you think of two views you
have in different areas of philosophy
that might contradict each other or hard
to reconcile
i mean in different areas of philosophy
i mean like in ethics and in metaphysics
or something like that
um i mean a lot of the views that i've
had about
things where i'm like well i believe
this and i believe this and they
contradict each other i
more or less worked through at this
point and i'd say well
maybe i keep some of this and some of
this or this has to go
and this doesn't have to go um that i
nothing really like pops into my mind
right away
[Music]
um here's a good one
who do you think are the most underrated
and overrated philosophers of the 20th
century i'd say wittgenstein for
overrated and whitehead for underrated
is the the what uh dialectic says
um i would agree about wittgenstein and
this has been
kind of there was a really interesting
twitter conversation about this a while
back
where somebody said name one of the main
contributions that wittgenstein
actually made to advancing philosophy
and people are like well this and this
and this and then they you know
he'd be like well that's already in this
person over here you know
um it's just the fact that the analytics
at the time weren't doing a lot of
reading you know
or what about this and i i do think that
wittgenstein
is quite overrated um
not to say that you know he doesn't have
some interesting ideas but they are not
as
absolutely revolutionary they were
revolutionary within a very
narrow context
i would say something similar about the
you know the revival of virtue ethics it
was only a revival within
analytic departments because people had
been doing virtue ethics
continuously during all of that time
um underrated
lav chest off you know i'm i'm a big fan
of
of chest off hardly anybody reads him uh
these days um
mock shaler you know he's a great
phenomenologist
that we should check out um
who else that's a good that's a good
question um
all right uh let's see here
rob asked any suggestion on texts that
introduced the history
and thinkers of early medieval thought
for example neoplatonism stoicism
christian mysticism
so stoicism is not part of early
medieval thought and neoplatonism had
largely been
absorbed into christian thought by that
time
if we're talking about early medieval
right so boethius would be a prime
example of somebody who knows the stoics
talks about them
is clearly a neo-platonic thinker
but also a christian thinker um
christian mysticism
i mean i'm not that's something i'm not
particularly
versed in or interested in i i'm i'm not
particularly interested in thinkers that
are associated with
mystical traditions i'm much more
interested in discursive traditions
um history and thinkers of early
medieval thought i mean if you're
talking about like textbooks i don't
know because i don't i don't
do a lot of secondary lit stuff
if you're asking about like who you
should read
so you know i mentioned boethius of
course
augustine gregory the great the guy it
was named after
you know like his morality on job um
we so if we're only talking about early
not like mid medieval thought i guess
we'd leave out
aerogena and alcohol and people like
that because that's carolingian
renaissance
in the 700s um
i mean simplicius is
pretty late right he's a neo-platonic
thinker
um he and he knows about christianity
he doesn't doesn't agree with it uh
that's a good question
i'd have to think about that more um
all right um
jimmy from hong kong asks in what sense
do you think stoicism and existentialism
are compatible
depends on whose existentialism you're
talking about there is no existentialism
per se
as a school there's a lot of
existentialists that are
engaging with common themes but often
have some serious differences between
each other
um i would say the emphasis on the
capacity to
choose for yourself the kind of person
that you're going to be
within determinate circumstances um
the importance of our relations with
others
is is often left out in popular
treatments of both stoicism and
existentialism but it's there in the
classic texts
so those would be some things whether we
do or don't have a human nature figuring
out what kind of things we are
that's that's a central thing as well
all right um so we're getting close to
the end
let me
[Applause]
scroll down and find some some other
good stuff um
here's an interesting question how do we
get from the extreme
anti-conventionalism of diogenes to the
conservativism and conventionalism of
the
imperial stoics we don't because both of
those are [ __ ]
diogenes is not an extreme
anti-conventionalist
if you read you know what we have uh
about him or uh connected with him he
actually thought that virtue is was
quite important and he's
um he is doing some things that are
anti-con
conventional right but he's trying to
bring us back to something
that is um you know
realizing our human nature and he
thought that wisdom mattered he thought
that virtue mattered
um he is probably the most extreme of
the the cynics but
he's also within a tradition that
includes antisthenes
and crates and hipparchia right and
um the conservativism and
conventionalism of the imperial stoics
um that's at best half true
um they were actually
quite uh
counter-cultural that's why they often
got themselves exiled or killed
right so whatever history of ideas
you're relying on that's getting you
those things i'd
probably call that into question um
all right let's scroll down a little bit
phil says what's your take on lawrence
becker's propositions for modern
stoicism do you think it's necessary to
update stoicism that way
so he doesn't have propositions he has a
whole book
and his whole book is a very tough book
that
it has a mystique sort of like i was
mentioning nick land
uh spinoza hegel right it's one of those
books that a lot of people buy
very few people read because it's a
difficult book
um he doesn't give a lot of examples
it's pretty dense
i took an entire four months to work
through it
you know meeting weekly with one of my
clients a couple years back
i think that many of the ideas that he's
putting on the table as
reinterpretations
of stoicism once understood
make a lot of sense understanding them
that's the trick
so you know he he is somebody who gave a
real
good kick in the pants along with
anthony long
and julianas and chris gill and people
like that to
academics taking stoicism seriously
but it's not an easy book to adapt
immediately for
for like a popular audience
all right uh
let's see what else can we pick up on
[Music]
oh here's a good question if we
translate this from xeno
if we transfer contents of the whole
brain into a computer is it still
human would it still have an essence
anymore
um it depends on what you call what you
think essence is
right um it's certainly partially human
or human derived
is it still human we'd have to ask about
like things that we do think about as
essential to human beings like does it
have the kind of agency that we do
is it able to reflect upon itself does
it communicate with other
minds you know does it does it have
memories does it
does it have feelings and things like
that
those those would be questions we'd want
to ask
all right um adam have i written any
books i'd be interested in reading and
thank you for everything yeah i was just
remarking on this earlier today on
social media i have written one book in
my life
uh it came out about 10 years ago it's
called
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
uh hasn't sold an awful lot of copies in
part because
catholic university of america press
priced it
a little bit beyond the break point
for people purchasing things it costs 75
bucks so it's kind of a
expensive book and as is often the case
with academic presses
you do not you do not become rich
writing
academic books um so
yeah it's i've written that one i i do
have other book projects but
i do so many other things that i think
it's difficult for me to
get them done um
harry talboys how much of an influence
do you think hegel was on
marks very significant influence marx
actually
um you know has a critique of the
philosophy of rights and he uses this
you know
notion of dialectic that is getting
partially from hegel but the influence
is not
you know like one to one kind of like
flowing into this
you got to remember that hegel was so
influential
that there was an entire milieu of
people
each with their own sort of
interpretation or version of what what
hegelianism
would mean or do and even people who are
anti-hegelian
like kierkegaard are still using a lot
of hegel's own ideas
you know um to develop their own
philosophy
so you know hegel is a significant
influence on marx
the master slave dialectic is not by the
way the key to understanding angles
influence on marx the way unfortunately
some people have
given them the idea that it is um
all right let's scroll down a little bit
more and see what else we've got
uh rob mcqueen do you have any plans to
cover the positive and negative theology
of pseudo-dianisos i do not
um although you know if i had a million
years maybe i would get around to that
so a lot of discussion here about
people giving book recommendations
um
well here's a here's a really good one
from mark
do i think it's fair that kant's moral
philosophy has often been criticized
for leaving emotions out of the equation
and moral action
um yeah i do think it's fair because
kant himself
is pretty clear about this that
there's only a very narrow range of
affective
you know emotional motives to action
that he calls
moral feeling that can properly
be a motivation to
moral action everything else like love
for you know like if you're a shopkeeper
and you
love humanity and because of that you
give people fair prices that's
that's you know it's not immoral but
it's it's
non-moral right um if i treat my kids
well because i love my kids
that's not you know that's not a moral
motive for things and and he is rightly
criticized for that i think
um i think that's that's a very
uh important area of our life
and i think was just there's something
that went wrong
you know maybe he's reacting too much to
the um focus on sentimentality
you know um but that that's that's a
legitimate criticism there
all right i'll go on on this venner dr
sailor now that you own a copy of faye
newman do you plan to make any videos on
its contents
yeah like i said earlier i'm going to be
doing a review
of the work as a whole and all i'll
probably do some things on some of the
essays that i think are particularly
worth working on and i will also this
summer
be on the
acid horizon podcast they they want me
to come on and talk about
one or more of the essays from fang
numina as well
so all right i have to go to the library
i got to venture out into the 90 degree
heat here
in milwaukee and i got to get myself a
book on philip jose farmer that that is
waiting for me there
um good questions uh hopefully
everything
uh was again i can't see
the sound thing on here so hopefully
people were actually able to hear me
um all right and uh
we'll see you next time got a lot of
other events coming up this month you
can always look at the reason
io calendar that's reasonio.com and then
go to events calendar or go to my
facebook page you can see
the other things that are coming up
thanks to everybody for their questions
and
comments it looks like there was a good
bit of back and forth between people
in the comments without getting into
antagonism that's always nice to see
all right i'll see all of you later